our correspondent and occasional guest
host Luke Beasley whose Channel you can
find at davidpackman.com Luke went to
Donald Trump's South Carolina event this
was that extraordinarily low energy
event that Jesse dolomore recovered for
us last week now this is a completely
whacked group of people that went to
this event and I'm gonna play some clips
of Luke speaking to them in a moment but
one of the things that many of you have
emailed me about is David I'm worried
about Luke many of you said it is is he
is he safe at these events and at this
event for the first time that I'm aware
of people started shouting insults and
threats to Luke as it became clear that
he was asking completely respectful but
certainly adversarial questions as he
conducted his interviews we're going to
get to that and we've got to talk about
Luke safety in a bit we're going to
first start with we will call him guy
number one let's just get right into it
I present these without any introduction
uh this is pretty wacky stuff buckle up
I know what the truth is and I believe
everything that's happened in January
6th is going to be revealed every bit of
it and now we know what happened on
January 6th I don't know exactly what
you're referring to so what would you
say that is what occurred on January 6th
talking about Nancy Pelosi which she
instigated
and the information she's got will be
found on her laptop
and that will be eventually it will be
revealed to the American people it's not
just Hunter's laptop now it's Nazi
Pelosi's as he says
so Nancy Pelosi Instagram January 6th
but she did what would be the purpose of
them coordinating this great question
what's the end game there the end game
is to get Trump out so he doesn't win
presidency of course Trump is out the
2020 election I believe was stolen I
think majority of the people here
believe that 2022 was stolen they did it
again so let me pause this to you
um if their goal was to get Trump out of
office and the certification was what
was going on during January 6th meaning
they were doing the process to get Trump
out of office right certifying Biden's
win then
causing January 6 would be the opposite
of what they would want because it
absolutely perfect question why would
they interrupt the process to remove
Trump if what they want to do is remove
Trump interfere with the certification
right I didn't get that last part the
actions of January 6 actually interfered
with the certification so doesn't it
kind of not make sense that the
Democrats would have instigated January
6 if that got in the way of the
certification which they wanted because
that was going to cause Biden to become
president
I just believe
that uh
I am not artificially extending this
silence folks just so you know
I don't know he doesn't know he doesn't
know presented with a simple question he
doesn't know still speaking to guy
number one here Trump is really in
control he says but if bad things happen
those aren't Trump's fault what and I
believe God is in charge of the whole
thing he's got everybody in the place
that he wants him at
if you put Trump in there in 2016.
and I actually believe that Trump is
President right now whoa really I do and
he's in in control to to the military is
this mental illness
the military has more power over the
federal government and state government
military law
how would you describe kind of I know
what happened they know what happened
during the election I believe they have
proof of it okay and that will be
revealed and right now how would you
describe the state of America
it's not good this is a brilliant set of
questions by Luke by the way he's really
getting good at this it's not good
comes in control would you blame him for
that
no no why not
well because I think things are getting
better
think of that folks Trump's really in
charge right now oh and how are things
going terribly so since Trump's in
charge is that his fault no why not
because things are getting better
absolutely brilliant absolutely
brilliant we then go to lady number one
let's see what she had to say to Luke
here besides Trump what do you want to
hear from him
I've heard everything I've wanted from
him
I want him to take down all the people
who are in place right now right
so this is a super simple question but
somehow I do get different uh answers to
it who's the president right now
hotel okay
he can't tell you who is president but
time will tell us it will come Out Come
On
We're Not Gonna Know I Know Okay God
knows and the woman knows who is
president but we're not gonna know
that's very very interesting now then we
go to guy number two guy number two
proposes a different idea altogether
about what took place on January 6th so
you brought up uh January 6 in the con
within the context of Nancy Pelosi her
son what do you think because I've heard
a number of different takes on this
if not the official narrative that we
all saw meaning Trump supporters angry
about the statements troubles making
attacking the capital what do you think
happened what was Nancy Pelosi and
coordinating or something right well
I've definitely investigated the
situation I was there
were buses that came in and all one has
to do is take pictures of those tags on
those buses
go to those bus companies and track who
paid for them you were there where I
drink this
yeah in the capital I was not on the
lawn the day before when Enrique a
member of The Proud boys was busted in
the airport with he's talking about
Enrique atario plastic magazines that
they retailed to try to make money for
their cause I knew that the mayor and
something was going on
so take a quick class the FBI hasn't
knocked on my door yet but I was smart
enough to turn around and get back yeah
he wasn't going to be picked up as a
patsy that's for sure so we're sticking
with this guy and he also seems to
stumble upon this idea that someone else
is in charge he believes it's Barack
Obama I believe the military is in
charge right now
oh this is what I've heard before so if
the military is in control do you mean
they're running everything Biden isn't
we know Biden's not
um Biden's definitely not running
anything I believe uh President Obama is
actually calling shots right now and
everything that I've researched is
pointing toward that do you understand
the amount of research this man has done
and all of it points to Obama is in
charge but
who's who's going to sit back and watch
all this happen Mike Lindell proves
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt that enough
cheating went on in that election that
it would have changed the outcome yeah
obviously many would say he didn't but
to move on from that speaking of Mike
obviously the facts don't point to that
at all Glendale
um he's predicted multiple times that by
this date Trump will take back over as
president the military will bring him in
does it not make you go oh wait maybe
the claims he's been making about other
things are also lies because he lied
about this or at least
falsely predicted something about this I
don't believe Mike lindell's got a bad
bone in his body he is a true Christian
I ministered for years this guy also not
only did he research and found that it's
Obama who's in charge he also was a
minister and knows that Mike Lindell is
really an amazing Christian okay now we
go to guy number three here was we start
with who is the president
um and it sounds like a simple question
but I get different answers to it who's
the president right now
definitely not Joe Biden
interesting and who is then the words
it's a I want to say it's uh we're being
it's a movie
if you think about it
I'm gonna need elaboration on that yeah
who's President not Biden who is
president well it's a movie
there's way too much things going on
behind the scenes to even look at what's
going on the mainstream TVs you
understand you can get that
all right and then I would be like no I
don't get that dude diving into that
what's going on behind the scenes
it's it's hard to even fathom what end
of the uh this guy clearly he knows
we're not getting the truth but he
doesn't know what the truth is
a good way to put that word for you it's
the amount of pedophilia that's in this
system is insane it's just jammed up are
you kind of just hearing that makes you
think of oh you know where I'm going you
and I do yeah no I understand accusing
and there's a lot of speculation there
but yeah I followed you
and uh it may not Shock you guys this is
a q Anon do your own research I just
don't hear speculation the funny thing
about do your own research is these
people all claim to be doing their own
research and they come away with crazy
ideas like for example uh you know
Trump's president or Obama's president
or Nancy Pelosi's laptop holds the key
or whatever whatever research they're
doing doesn't seem to be getting them
any closer to sanity you can pull up
your own information and it's Crystal
Clear do you know Mike Lindell yeah
so one of the things he's
a good example to me of this phenomenon
that I see a lot in what would be called
conspiracy theory circles is making a
bold prediction Trump's going to become
president by this period of time it
doesn't happen and then I get confused
because the followers don't stop
trusting you Mike Lindell is predicted
just around the corner Trump's going to
be by this August whatever then that
hasn't happened or I agree and why
doesn't that cause you not to support
them and think oh maybe what they're
selling me is
dishonest great question
um things have uh they have channels
they have to go through and things have
to happen in certain
way to happen
even if it takes 50 years so
all right I'm sorry I'm on the spot yeah
I got you um all right so anyway this
guy loses his train of thought and it
only goes downhill from there then we
get to guy number four and hear the
threats start from off camera
good criticism of any system throughout
this country is necessary I don't think
suppressing any type of criticism wrong
or right uh is is that thing I'm gonna
get to you next just try not to be too
loud so now this there's someone hurling
hurling uh abuse at Luke and then it
gets worse
oh God this is exactly the stuff we were
all worried about right and so this is
something we're going to have to talk
about because this gets much worse and
as you can see people looking around now
looking over what's going on here
um okay
that's it Oh I thought you're talking
about with our election processes
with our
you gotta come interview if you're gonna
be making all that noise
now other people start coming over
saying well dude you got to calm down
and I understand
Luke's doing a really good job here but
this is what when you're trying to focus
in and do an interview and there's
someone so close screaming stuff this
loudly at you
it is not comfortable
[Music]
hey guys that's right it's all right
it's right that's right now in in the
defense of some of these folks they're
some of these Trump people are actually
telling this guy hey you got to lay off
that's right listen we're all Americans
here and we love like see this is the
problem this is the problem
I wish like people like you and me could
sit and have these discussions that's
why I'm here 100 like so if you're still
taking someone else's word for it you're
still believing into someone saying hey
hey trust me
and this is the biggest see this is the
biggest problem now we need to have
discussions like this but there's always
going to be like a subset of the
population that's going to
yeah I'm with you yeah so Luke uh visit
visibly flustered there
um we then speak to a guy who believes
that there's demonic oppression and
Trump is really president the guy's also
wearing a star of David uh again just to
just uh
um remember folks most American Jews are
very liberal most American Jews do not
believe in demonic possession most
American Jews do not believe Trump is
really the president all right uh what
about you here what are you hoping to
see and hear I'm hoping to see the
president of the United States Donald
Trump and I came here because this
country is in such bondage in such
demonic oppression we are heading
towards commune it's in bondage and it's
been afflicted by Sato masochism as well
we need need people to be praying for
this hold on I talked just go back a
second Russian we are heading towards
communism we need people to be praying
for this country to be praying for the
president Donald Trump
and to pray for people's eyes to be
opened so the truth of where our
country's heading because communism is a
very real thing it's it's real there is
no communism in the United States
Marxism is a very real thing we have
Marxist running our country who we have
babies being killed after they're born
no we have all of these are trying to
take away our first amendment no trying
to take away our Second Amendment no
they're trying to destroy our
constitution let's do it one bit at a
time so you start off by saying
president United States is that kind of
because we love them or because you
genuinely believe he's still the
president
both okay
um then speaking to a guy with a let's
go Brandon fjb sweater and check out the
word salad this guy delivers when Luke
asks about the classified documents
double standard uh what's your response
to the Biden classified documents
Scandal yeah it's just hypocritical man
the way they responded to trumps and
then not so much Scandal to his on the
media just really shows the power
between the two parties but I think this
does play a lot better into Trump's
favorite because they've really quieted
down more on his media side ever since
that happened yeah so I have heard a lot
of the complaints from the right kind of
being double standard the doj's too
aggressive of trump they rate him but
wouldn't you agree there's very
different facts in the situation Trump
withholding the documents were inviting
gave them up immediately
yeah it's just really just honestly a
personal standpoint at that point kind
of shows this is where it goes off the
rails what is this guy talking about a
person that Trump is versus the kind of
person that Biden is to where Trump's
gonna stand for his word and what he
believes is what's going to be his way
is just going to play towards the system
which he's basically bought into and
just kind of leaning towards that side
of it but if it would be illegal to have
those documents that is a positive to
stick to his his principles at that
point you're already guilty for what
you're having like I'm not gonna keep on
it but yeah at that point I was like in
incredible I mean so sometimes it I
really do get the impression the people
who are sometimes weighing in on this
stuff have never actually thought
through their opinion until the
microphones in front of their face and
they would be much better off just
saying hey you know what I haven't
really thought about that let me I
should think about that before I give
you an opinion but they the mic is there
and the camera turns on and they'll
weigh in on whatever
um really good job by Luke you can find
Luke Beasley's channel uh go to
davidpackman.com Luke and we are going
to have to have a conversation about
Luke's safety at these events because
this would this one started to get quite
ugly and uh it's something we're going
to talk about all right all of these
clips find them on our YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show we
will have these on tick tocks and Tick
Tock we will have them on Instagram
Facebook everywhere excellent job by
Luke we'll take a quick break and be
right back
let's talk about plastic 100 billion
plastic bags are used and thrown away
each year huge contributor to plastic
waste you might think there's no way
around it think again our sponsor hold
on bags makes trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based and non-toxic so they break
down in weeks rather than decades and
they don't fill up our landfills or
pollute our oceans hold on zip seal
kitchen bags come in sandwich or gallon
sizes for all of your needs and because
they are plant-based hold on trash bags
and their zip seal kitchen bags are 100
home compostable so what I do is I put
my food garbage in a hold on bag throw
the whole thing into the compost pile
it's fantastic but even for everyday
garbage I'm putting in the dumpster
there is something really simple and
easy I can do to make a difference just
to save plastic to shop plant-based bags
and replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to holdon bags.com Pacman
use the code Pacman for twenty percent
off the link is down below